Governor Gavin Newsom is left outraged
as Republican Governor send migrants on
a one-way ticket out of their states
putting the pressure on Sanctuary cities
but one Latina Democrat is calling out
her own party over the Border she's
joining us now she's the former
California state Senator Gloria Romero
and we also have with us one of our
favorite guests Fox News contributor Leo
Terrell welcome Leo welcome Gloria so
we'll start with you Gloria on this
topic of the governor sending the the
migrants for example to Martha's
Vineyard and I think what I found
interesting about your remarks
especially you as a Democrat is that
your your remarks highlight the elitism
of it all explain
absolutely I mean think about the irony
it's the beginning of Hispanic Heritage
Month and we are a lot more than just a
bunch of diverse breakfast tacos by the
way so here we are facing a border that
has not been secured for quite some time
over two million uh migrants coming
through and it took only 50 brown people
showing up in one of the most exclusive
Democratic enclaves without leaf blowers
and without mops for it to be declared a
national emergency and to get the media
focused on this it's absolutely
hypocritical and many Latinos like
myself we consider ourselves Democrats
but we are completely disaffected
disenchanted with how we have been
treated and how this issue has not been
properly addressed by Democratic party
overall yeah there's no question that
Martha's Vineyard is better prepared
financially to handle those migrants
then you know Uvalde and many of these
other working-class poor towns that have
had to bear bear the brunt of this and
many of those towns also in California
Leo I'm going to come to you you're
coming to us from California your
Governor says he wants to to to
basically charge Governor DeSantis with
kidnapping uh what do you what do you
make of this as a lawyer and a
Californian
uh in salty and I'll tell you right now
uh Governor Newsom is a very insecure
Governor uh Rachel I live in the state
of California the most incompetent
governor in the country let me be very
clear he doesn't even know what
kidnapping is the Democrats have been
flying migrants all over this country
for the last year and a half what he's
trying to do uh Rachel is is kick start
his campaign for president he's trying
to get a national profile they're still
kidnapping here at all he knows it he's
not a lawyer he doesn't know what he's
talking about but this is the double
standards that the Democrats have used
over and over again they make the
assumption that they're they care about
people that look like myself and Gloria
but they don't they use us and this
whole argument of kidnapping is nothing
more than a political stunt but to
kick-start his campaign for president
and he will never become president of
this country this country does not want
to turn into California which is a
disaster
yeah I mean Gloria obviously Leo brings
up some great points about the governor
but it is so interesting how liberals
you know wrap all of these policies up
in compassion we've had you know 50
migrants being cooked alive in a bus
um we have sex trafficking I mean our
own government is complicit in the sex
trafficking as Leo brought up we do the
last leg for this for these evil cartels
and now they want to get upset about
some of them getting sent from States
like Florida which is a non-sanctuary
state over to states and cities that are
supposedly Sanctuary states and cities
exactly and that's why so many Latinos
and Democrats within the party are just
sick and tired of this we've seen across
the country people Latinas like Myra
Flores in a democratic stronghold
historically winning and more and more
Latinos such as myself are willing to
say yes we're Democrats but we are not
bound to the party we are Americans
first we want border security we believe
in citizenship we are a patriotic
community and we want respect and fair
comprehensive immigration reform that
has not been delivered to us and we're
going to keep fighting for that until we
get that and and calling out the
hypocrisy that has been exposed by
Martha's Vineyard and their so-called
you know compassionate treatment of all
lives matter it's a bunch of BS unless
you have a leaf blower and a mop in hand
it appears yeah that's exactly right
unless you're there to to work in their
homes and trim their Hedges they don't
want you on Martha's Vineyard that's
very clear
last word for to you really quickly Leo
I want to be very clear I heard your
segment with the lieutenant governor of
Texas declare an evasion take this case
back up to a supreme court that will
enforce the law because what is
happening is there's no solution I got
news for you uh Rachel the Democrats
want to keep this home this illegal
alien issue going they don't want to
resolve it take this matter up to the
Supreme Court for the governor of Texas
to declare an invasion and let the
Supreme Court decide this case revisit
the Arizona case right now we need to do
something because the Biden
Administration is doing absolutely
nothing well it looks like the governor
in Arizona or the the in the midterms
there might be a new governor in Arizona
who might be willing to do that very
thing so Leo Gloria so great to have
your voices on thanks for joining us
this morning I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis